also in today's speech joe biden tried a
180 as it relates to funding of the
police
i know we expect so much from our law
enforcement officers
so we need to support them
that's why my crime plan to help
communities recruit hire and train
nationwide more than one hundred
thousand additional officers accountable
officers
for community policing folks when it
comes to fighting crime
we know it works
yeah we know it works joining us now is
former acting department of homeland
security secretary chad wolfe uh chad uh
the lip service eh that's real nice but
uh wouldn't this be more effective if he
also called out the district attorneys
that are going soft on crime and
criminals in their own locale localities
well absolutely not only the district
attorneys but it would have been nice in
2020 while president biden was on the
campaign trail to actually talk about
the violence uh and the defund the
police movement that we saw during the
civil unrest in in the summer of 2020
but absolutely silent on that front as
well and again this is an administration
and a president that continues to talk
about there's actually language in an
executive order that they have put out
this year that talks about how the
criminal justice system and police
officers are systemic racist
and so the list goes on and on look you
have border patrol officers who are
sworn law enforcement officers that they
will attack for doing their jobs on
horseback um so i think that the facts
are out there that this administration i
think is politically convenient right
he's now talking about supporting law
enforcement when you're a couple of
months out from a midterm election but i
think if you look at the facts and you
look at the data time and time again
when they should be supporting law
enforcement they actually do the
opposite and they're not supporting it
with any resources and certainly not
with any leadership yeah my guess is
that they did out went out and did some
fresh polling did some focus groups and
realized they were upside down on crime
surprise surprise uh and decided to
change their story uh and is there a
total disconnect i think between
oh having totally opened borders and
then suddenly going to pennsylvania
saying hey we're going to be on tough on
crime listen to the president today he
spoke about his interaction with the
people in mexico
you know what the mexicans are
mexico which has real problems causing
us real problems you know what their
biggest complaint is
can't we stop
gun trafficking across the southern
border in new mexico
have you heard that before i mean that
that's his big concern is that there are
too many weapons flowing from the north
to the south
well to be to be honest i'm not really
concerned about what mexicans think i'm
concerned about what americans think and
i'm concerned about putting americans
first and this administration time and
time again refuses to acknowledge that
there is a border crisis of their own
making the president refuses to go to
the border the vice president refuses to
go to the border they refuse to listen
to law enforcement officers you have the
chief of the border patrol on record in
the last day or so saying that the the
cause of this crisis is because there
are no consequences to illegal behavior
and this is a system that they have set
up and designed they do not apologize
for it and they actually brag about it
and so for the president to sit there
and talk about what mexicans are
thinking and feeling he should he should
really stop and think about that and say
i'm actually president of the united
states and maybe i should be putting
together policies and thinking about
what's best for americans
this gets me hot and bothered at the end
of the day because he's not doing his
job this administration refuses to
enforce
laws on the border and it's causing an
unmitigated disaster when you have over
a hundred thousand overdose deaths
because of fentanyl
90 percent of that comes across that
southern border so if he wants to
protect americans he wants to be on the
side of law enforcement it's time to do
your job along that border and solve the
crisis that we have today yeah and maybe
joe could actually go down to the border
the first time in his 50-plus years in
his pub with public service and i'm glad
he's going to pennsylvania twice in one
week but why not try going texas arizona
uh new mexico or california on the
border and talking to actual border
patrol agents i think that would do the
trick as well
chad wolfe thank you so much for joining
us tonight hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else